what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to kevin samuels and
brittany reiner before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um
just to put everything in context my dad
is in the top half a percent of earners
so i have
a little bit of insight into the
lifestyle that a lot of women say that
they want but i don't necessarily think
they always do
okay
then you have the things that we feel
like we need
cool
but you can't have it all it's like um
it's like you can't have this life and
then have a normal private life
right you can't because it's too public
who you don't know who you're meeting
you don't know why you're meeting them
and you've got to calculate every time
you meet somebody
what's the damage that can be done to
the end goal because you're youth
that's not normal
it's not so that so that comes along
with it so
all things being equal
what matters more in the long-term team
is it the family life
that kind of stuff
uh and still living a a decent life or
is it
the
speaking your truth
uh
okay let me just pause right there the
biggest lie that we have told women is
that you can have everything
um i'm gonna give you an example so my
mom met my dad
they dated for two years in college
and my dad and my mom did distance for
two years
after two years sorry my dog is snoring
my dad told my mom to either move to him
or get a new
boyfriend
and my mom
seeing the potential my dad decided to
move for him and she ended up getting a
degree to become a teacher and quitting
that to go work for my
dad she didn't get her own career it was
my dad's career my dad's idea that she
followed
um
yeah so a lot of girls think they can
have everything and you just simply
can't and the whole wendy williams kind
of thing we were talking about
see i think that's a good question but
i almost feel like
i can't get too far away from the empire
because
if i get too far from the empire
any man that i'm with at some point in
time i'm gonna have to get in compliance
and kind of sign up for whatever his set
of rules are
right get on his program i should say
and
i am well aware of what's out there i'm
well aware
a lot of guys are going to steer clear
of me which is fine so that's why as
much as i so the one thing i respect
about her is she understands the men's
point of view and she really doesn't
shame them for wanting what they want at
least in this interview yeah i don't
follow her exclusively
um however
guys there is a price to everything and
there is a price
to having your ass out on instagram
i'm sorry ladies
if i was telling a girl that wanted to
be wifed that is the first thing i would
tell her take away all of your ass pics
take away all of your boob pics on
instagram like show like less is more
and when you come to a guy and you're
not dressing super provocatively you're
not
putting your body out there for the
world to see that is a breath of fresh
air and if you guys look at my instagram
it's not provocative i don't i don't
even have
a true like bikini picture on there
i think oh no i had a high waisted one
i'm sorry i'm sorry if that crosses the
line for you let me know but but you
guys understand when i talk to guys
about this
it it's a fresh of breath a breath of
fresh air because women today
need that attention and need that
validation because it's so readily
available to us
and that's fine if you want to do that
but everything comes with a cost you
cannot have everything
want the family i want the matching
pajamas on christmas
it's almost like i can't really put all
of my eggs in that
because i'm going to have to make sure
me and my son are financially okay no
matter what happens to his dad no matter
what is to come i feel like i can't just
say i just want a family like i did that
i wasn't really posting on social media
i had to kind of trade off you want to
be able to sit at home not work well
there's certain things you're not gonna
post
well
i often hear women say these
paradoxical things that
i want a family
but it's almost like you want family
without the compliance
it's not that there's anything wrong
with getting into compliance i just feel
like
when you are under a man's roof under
his law
if you're not okay with certain things
the only way that you can is if you have
your own thing
so it's like if if i don't like your set
of rules and i don't have anything to
fall back on then what am i going to do
like i have to be able to stand on my
own so it's not that empire's more well
i mean
see and this is where
and this is
the problem we have today we are so
afraid
to go in on something as people like we
are so afraid to go all in on something
in fear of getting hurt
and it's you know
it's a fair fear i mean 50 of marriages
don't work out but
if you live your life
always
making decisions out of fear you will
never achieve like the level of
happiness that you want
because
what decision that you have made out of
fear has ended up being good for you
so
okay
we ended up getting to the so at the end
of the day it's you
ahead of the things you say you want
because what i mean
human beings are meant to pair up and be
in family units that's what we meant to
be so it's like what i'm hearing is what
i typically hear fear scarcity in life
it's like well i can't put all my eggs
in a basket with a man because it could
go awry so i need to have an extra
extra strategy and a backup plan
okay
and no matter how we get to it it's one
foot in one foot out
because you can't because it's like if
you're in a on a men's program
the implication of being on a man's
program is some inherently fraught with
risk and somehow negative
i can only speak from my personal
experience and when i was i will say
this is the one thing that was really
different about my upbringing than
the manosphere seems to
push my dad is very much
you guys are not my problem like
it's funny i was telling my dad
that he should pick out my husband
i'm thinking dad that's your job
and he tell looks at me and he tells me
you are 18. you are over the age of 18
you are not my problem anymore and he
really was never controlling of my mom
and gave her all these rules he
is a big believer in letting people do
what they're going to do and making
decisions based off of that
with my child's father there were kind
of a certain set of expectations for
that relationship and if i didn't want
to have to pay bills didn't want to work
didn't want to there was
you could have the car where the 1.6
million dollar home like you really just
kind of sit down shut up suck a dick and
be pretty and that's cool like some
women sign up for that but i do think
too like you said they are allowed to
weigh their options i can't remember the
terminology that you use
high-value men don't cheat the exercise
right the exercise options so to me i
feel like unless you are ready to comply
to whatever demands or rules that they
have then how can i comfortably
just say i'm just all about family well
well
i mean a lot of goes into that too
because it depends on the kind of men
you deal with
look at the kind of man you deal with
the age of the man
the environment they live in i mean
the the stuff that i think of when
you're talking about that
i come from the corporate world it's not
it's not like the money isn't the same
but it's
it's a different way
it's a different thing so at the end of
the day
what i'm hearing is
from what you've been where you've been
you know i need to insure myself
fine fine
um but once that's insured is that
enough
of course it's not i could have 100
million in my account right now and i'm
still going to be a miserable [ __ ] so
this is why i'm such a big this is why
i'm such a big um
advocate for therapy especially in black
community we don't learn how to do
relationships right we don't we don't
trust each other we barely like each
other we hate [ __ ] a lot yeah so
and
and to be some of the most romantic
dreamy people
when it comes down to relationships we
don't really speak fairly highly of them
no so how do we fix that if
you got to protect you
and men feel like they can't trust women
like you
that's a fair question it's it's like
and here's the thing who drops the who
drops who's who gives up first who says
all right i'm tired of fighting i'm
tired of warring
okay
guys if you
want someone in your life a genuine
apology goes so far it goes so far
a lot of guys will talk a big game but
if their ex-girlfriend came up to them
and said look i messed up
i thought i could do better i clearly
couldn't
uh i'm willing to get on your program
100
assuming she didn't do anything crazy
maybe she leaves out that i thought i
could do better part i don't know but if
she gave you a genuine apology half of
these guys cap they would take that girl
back and a lot of times we leave
situations out of fear scarcity and lack
like kevin samuel says
and
it's okay to admit you had messed up
sometimes
it's it's okay i think you know many
times my parents had to apologize to
each other over the years
and it's funny because
the manosphere preaches you know they
say apologize as little as possible and
it's just interesting because that is
not
how i've seen my parents relationship
work do the women die or do demand stop
well how do i how would i get a man to
trust me i feel like the only way maybe
a man would trust someone like me is if
i had my own and i could ask you a
question
if you have an answer i'd love to hear
it i feel like how else am i supposed to
if cause most of the time you talk you
say i feel
women run your feelings to your logic
that's fine you're logic through your
feelings that's fine i feel i feel i get
it uh
how do you get to well one way is
uh ditch the rebel
did you want me to ditch a part of who i
am well
okay that's a big cost for me uh then
just like a man choosing to to have a
family he has to ditch the bachelor
yeah
that's true that's absolutely true my
mom
my mom was a big drinker in high school
i mean she got married young she met my
dad when she was 17. but
my mom's always had a little bit of like
a wild streak in her like she'd go to
the bars with us and stuff when we were
a little bit older
but my mom played a role she cooked for
us she cleaned for us she
my mom worked so incredibly hard i have
such good parents i can't even cap
hey you can't you can't get it any other
way
okay and the other thing that they talk
about here
is
they mentioned earlier that high value
men cheat
and or their exercise option whatever
whatever kevin samuel says but this is
the thing that people don't understand
my ex-boyfriend he had a ton of
followers like literally so famous
and it gives you a whole new level of
insecurities knowing that all of those
girls are just like an inbox away now
you know nothing ever happened he
nothing like that happened right
and
even even though nothing happened
[Music]
you have to have a whole new level of
like security in yourself and your
relationship and you have to deal with
people with comments with the outside
world like talking with
and that stuff puts a strain on your
relationship you cannot have everything
you want a guy with status
that's what you guys want
but i hope i hope you are ready for what
comes with it and that's knowing that
you could be replaced
like that
um but let me know in the comments you
guys don't forget to like comment and
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i will talk to you
guys next time